here one week from election day we do
have one final snapshot of Nevada's
biggest races it's a new eight news now
Emerson College the hill poll as
politics now host John lingler explains
the political picture is getting clearer
spoiler alert based on this new polling
Republicans are leading almost every
major race in Nevada and the Gap is
getting bigger if that comes true next
week it would Mark a major shift in
state and National politics
for Democrats trying to hold on to their
political careers the news is not good
the new 8 news now Emerson College the
hill poll shows in the Senate Republican
Challenger Adam laxalt leading incumbent
Democrat Senator Catherine Cortez masto
by Five Points 50 to 45 percent that
marks an eight point gain for laxalt
from our last poll in September there's
also been a big swing among the key
Latino vote in Nevada laxalt leads
Cortez mazdo 54 to 41 percent that's a
huge change from September when the
senator led by 19 points Congressional
races follow a similar Trend with
Republicans pulling ahead in all but one
contest in District One congresswoman
Dina Titus is behind Republican
Challenger Mark Robertson by 10 points
in District 3 Republican April Becker
leads Democrat representative Susie Lee
51 to 47 percent only in District 4 does
democratic incumbent Stephen Horsford
hold on to a slim three-point advantage
over Republican Sam Peters one major
reason Democrats are struggling is the
lack of support for President Joe Biden
55 percent of nevadans disapprove of his
work just 40 percent support the
president and a hypothetical runoff with
former president Trump Mr Biden would
lose
the number of undecided voters is also
down our poll shows most abandons have
made up their mind and suggests they
want change John langler 8 News Now